.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO NEED A
BIGGER BOAT.
I AM TAKING THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS.
>> LOOK, YOU MADE A SMALL MOVE
TOWARD THE BUZZER, AND THEN YOU
STOPPED YOURSELF.
>> HIT THE BUZZER.
>> IS THAT BECAUSE YOU WEREN'T
ON CAMERA.
>> THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS --
GUARANTEED!
WOO!
♪
>> HEY, HO!
>> MAGIC CITY HERE.
MONEY IN THE AIR.
>> MONEY IN THE AIR.
>> HEY.
>> MONEY IN AIR.
>> MONEY, CHUCK.
>> MAKE IT RAIN.
>> MAN ALIVE.
CHUCKSTER.
>> COME ON, YOU GONNA COME WITH
IT, COME WITH IT RIGHT.
DON'T BE PLAYING HALF STEPPING
IN ATLANTA.
COME ON, DON'T BE HALF STEPPING.
♪
>> MAGIC CITY, HERE WE COME.
>> HERE THEY COME.
HEY, HEY.
>> PUT THAT ON THE GIF.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT, SHAQ?
>> LET'S SEE.
>> COME ON, DON'T HALF DO IT.
>> DO HALFWAY DOING IT.
>> COMING UP NEXT -- AUTO.
>> SHAQ, THAT'S HOW YOU DO IT.
>> MAGIC CITY, HERE WE COME.
>> MONEY IN TH